juste en quoi consiste le travail de la
braven
mais la bravm c'est une en fait c'est
une unité de maintien de l'ordre comme
les CRS comme les gendarmes mobiles et
donc les effectifs de la bravème
appartiennent à ce qu'on appelle les
compagnies d'intervention de la
préfecture de police de Paris donc ils
font du maintien de l'ordre et pour
certains d'entre eux nous les faisons
monter à moto pour qu'ils puissent se
déplacer plus rapidement et
notamment dans Paris quand des groupes
de manifestants
échappent du cortège et commettent des
exactions ou le soir quand il y a des
cortèges chômages des manifestations non
déclarées on a parfois des groupes
d'individus qui partent et qui
commettent des exactions comme on l'a vu
ces derniers soirs qui qui mettent le
feu aux poubelles qui dégradent des
magasins qui peuvent mettre le feu à des
véhicules et donc la Bravet sa
principale caractéristique c'est qu'elle
se déplace beaucoup plus vite mais
automatiquement nos effectifs descendent
de moto mettre pied-à-terre comme on le
voit d'ailleurs sur cette image et puis
se constituer en unité et font du
maintien de l'ordre c'est-à-dire que
leur but c'est soit de disperser un
attroupement soit d'interpeller soit
d'interpeller des individus qui
commettent des violences ou les
exactions et donc c'est une unité de
maintien de l'ordre avec des individus
qui sont formés pour faire du maintien
de l'or quoi pourquoi il fait autant
polémique cette cette brigade elle fait
polémique parce que
d'abord c'est moi qui la dirige c'est
moi qui l'engage et on l'engage toujours
sur les groupes les plus à risque les
groupes les plus violents et donc quand
elle intervient évidemment elle a
toujours beaucoup d'adversité en face
d'elle ils prennent beaucoup de
projectiles et donc ils sont pris à
partie et donc évidemment elle est
obligée souvent de faire un usage
proportionné de la force et ce sont
souvent ces vidéos que l'on voit tourner
qui en réalité traduisent l'action de la
braven qui va toujours au contact parce
qu'elle a toujours à gérer elle est plus
exposée si vous voulez elle va toujours
gérer des groupes qui sont les plus
radicaux les plus dangereux et c'est
toujours dans ces cas-là qu'on l'engage
mais je veux aussi profiter pour dire à
l'ensemble de vos téléspectateurs que
c'est beaucoup regarder soit plus que
sur BFM hier quand nous gérons quand
nous gérons des magnifiques quand nous
gérons des manifestations la doctrine
que nous mettons en œuvre c'est ce qu'on
appelle une doctrine de mise à distance
de désescalade nous ne sommes pas
présents les forces de l'ordre ne sont
pas présents et quand nous avons
intervenir c'est forcément parce qu'il y
a des violences de commise et il faut le
rappeler notre but évidemment c'est pas
de casser les manifestations la force et
l'honneur des policiers de la préfecture
de police et des gendarmes puisque
j'engage aussi beaucoup de gendarmes
mobiles aux côtés de mes effectifs la
force notre force c'est justement de
permettre que le droit de manifester
s'exerce justement quand on est préfet
de police de Paris quand on apprend
quand enfin quand on suit et qu'on voit
que Isabelle borne vient d'utiliser le
49-3 pour faire passer la réforme des
retraites est-ce qu'on se dit dans sa
tête ou là on va avoir du boulot non on
va pas on n'a pas de on intègre pas ce
type de paramètres on sait que un
certain nombre de manifestations peuvent
déjà dégénérer quel qu'en soit la cause
vous savez ce qui fait des générer les
manifestations actuellement vous savez
on a eu 10 inter syndicales qui se sont
très bien passé dans les cortèges
syndicaux en revanche on sait que dans
les pré-cortèges c'est-à-dire dans ces
manifestants qui viennent devant les
organisations syndicales qui parfois
atteignent un chiffre de 10 à 15000 qui
sont devant les organisations syndicales
on sait que c'est à l'intérieur de ce
précurtel que se constitue des Black
Blocs et quel que soit la cause de la
manifestation dès lors que ces
manifestations sont importantes en
général les Black Blocs instrumentalisés
par l'ultra gauche par des éléments
radicaux se constituent et commettent
des exactions quand on entend des
manifestants qui sont là vraiment pour
exercer leurs droits de manifester dire
on a subi énormément de violences est-ce
que ça vous revient ça et qu'est-ce que
vous dites à vos troupes d'abord métro
elles connaissent la doctrine pour
chaque manifestation se réunit on
définit notre mode opératoire c'est
toujours la mise à distance donc les
manifestants subissent pas de violence
ceux qui commettent des exactions
évidemment nous allons au contact pour
les interpeller les empêcher de nuire
mais nous n'intervenons jamais j'insiste
beaucoup là-dessus en dehors des cas de
violence c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
j'ai invité un certain nombre de
victimes collatérales parfois non il y a
pas de victimes collatérale non il n'y a
pas de victimes collatérale la réponse
de la police elle est toujours
proportionnée évidemment que quand les
policiers des pavés sont agressés sont
attaqués évidemment que nourripostons
mais de manière toujours toujours
proportionnée et quand il y a des
dérouillages il y a pas eu de dérapages
mais quand il y a des dérapages à les
venir quand il y a des dérapages vous
savez pour les policiers c'est compliqué
c'est toujours l'inspection générale de
la police nationale ou l'inspection
générale de la gendarmerie nationale
pour les gendarmes et qui sont à ce
moment-là obligés de s'expliquer et
parfois même poursuivi en judiciaire
donc il faut pas penser que les
policiers échappent à toute poursuite
d'ailleurs Gérald Darmanin a rappelé
juste titre hier encore que les
policiers c'est 7% de la fonction
publique et 55% des sanctions qui sont
appliquées alors d'ailleurs on en a
parlé encore vendredi
aujourd'hui le rôle de la bravm c'est
vraiment de se focaliser sur les
casseurs oui c'est la brigade de
répression des actions violentes et donc
c'est une unité de maintien de l'ordre
qui va être prioritairement projeté sur
les groupes à risque mais parfois ce
sont des CRS parfois ce sont des
gendarmes mobiles donc évidemment ils
sont un peu plus exposés que les autres
parce qu'on les envoie toujours sur des
groupes violents et surtout de manière
extrêmement mobile c'est ce qui fait la
force de cette unité qui est pour nous
absolument indispensable pour maintenir
l'ordre républicain dans Paris alors il
essaie de préfet de police de Paris
j'aimerais vous mettre face à des images
ce soir qui ont posé problème en plus
vous avez accepté et dit voilà où je
suis des images qui des vidéos qui font
polémiques j'aimerais d'abord qu'on voit
cette vidéo qui avait soulevé une grande
indignation une grande indignation qui
date du 20 mars dernier un jeune
étudiant tchadien avait été victime de
propos assez dur de la part des membres
de la brave
entendu cet audio évidemment les propos
qui sont tenus sont et que ça
inacceptables ce sont des paroles donc
ce ne sont pas des des fêtes de violence
physique mais ce sont des paroles qui
sont des paroles graves dont certaines
sont susceptibles de de tomber sous le
coup de qualificatif pénaux et donc
évidemment j'ai immédiatement saisi
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale vous savez qu'il y a une
enquête judiciaire qui est par ailleurs
dirigeante cette enquête est en cours
alors il y a une autre image aussi qui a
énormément fait c'est parler c'est cet
homme qui prend un coup de poing de la
part d'un membre apparemment sera un
membre de la braven regardez
là-dessus aussi vous avez vous demandez
ce qui s'est passé vous dites d'abord ce
que je voulais dire sur la séquence
précédente c'est que la séquence
précédente elle ne convient pas du tout
comme à l'ensemble des fonctionnaires de
la préfecture de police et de la braven
évidemment ça jette le propre sur toute
une toute notre famille finalement parce
que la préfecture de police c'est une
grande famille
sur cette vidéo que vous allez
évidemment on voit toujours la fin des
séquences donc
là aussi la justice est saisie il y a
une enquête l'IGPN investiges
on verra si cet acte était proportionné
ou pas moi je ne sais pas vous le dire
là s'il a été proportionné ça peut vous
paraître surprenant mais cette action là
c'est effectivement la braven qui est en
action qui est en train d'interpeller un
individu qui est casse le kiosque que
vous voyez juste là à l'image et donc un
individu est en train d'interpeller par
la Bravet mais vous avez tout un tas
d'individus qui empêche cette
interpellation dont l'individu qui chut
au sol et l'enquête elle va précisément
servir à déterminer si l'acte est
proportionné ou pas moi je n'en sais
rien moi je ne préjuge pas vous faites
une enquête et il y a une enquête en
cours mais je ne préjuge pas que ce soit
un acte disproportionné nous verrons
bien cet homme a été pris en charge
ensuite d'ailleurs par les effectifs de
police et notamment par un un sauveteur
qui faisait partie de la préfecture de
police et ensuite il est reparti moi je
ne préjugue pas de ce qui s'est passé
c'est ce qu'il faut bien comprendre il y
a une enquête il faut laisser le temps
aux investigations de se dérouler alors
cette question il y a une question qui
tourne c'est la dissolution de la bravem
il y a une pétition officielle qui a été
lancée sur le site de l'Assemblée
nationale comme tout citoyen peut le
faire apparemment et elle demande la
dissolution de la braven recueilli 250
000 signatures et Jean-Luc Mélenchon
bien sûr fait beaucoup parler à beaucoup
parler de la braven il y a eu des mots
très forts non seulement il est
dégagerait mais assez lieux ces agents
ces agents devraient même se faire
soigner regardez ce qu'elle dit Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
c'est une unité on a connu ça autrefois
ça s'appelait les Voltigeurs
motocyclistes après la mort de Malik ou
c'est King il était apparu ce qui était
une évidence que deux hommes jeunes sur
une moto dans la furie d'un d'un soir
dont tu as une matraque clairement ça
finit toujours mal ce n'est pas une
activité normale d'être candidat pour
aller frapper à deux sur une moto des
gens dans la rue et Monsieur Jeanne
j'ajoute que si cela finira par se
produire il y a un gouvernement de la
nups en jour ou l'autre nous dissoudrons
évidemment si ça n'est pas fait mais
c'est pas tout mais je vous enverrons
ces jeunes gens se faire soigner
alors Jean-Luc Mélenchon alors on sait
que
les membres des forces de l'ordre
parlent souvent de Jean-Luc Mélenchon
puisqu'il serait qu'il est pas tendra
avec eux quand vous l'entendez dire ça
vous vous dites quoi d'abord sur le fond
je voudrais corriger une ligne
exactitude qui est dans la bouche de
beaucoup de commentateurs pas que de
volts sur les voltigeur l'assimilation
qui est faite avec les vols et il faut
dans les années 80 vous aviez des unités
comme la brave qui circulaient à moto
mais le passager faisait de leur public
à moto donc ils avaient une espèce de
trick et ça n'a absolument rien à voir
nous c'est un moyen de déplacement et
dans la doctrine d'emploi c'est
totalement proscrit et quand nous quand
nous si nous avions enregistré un
dérapage un passager qui commettrait des
qui exercera des actes de maintien de
l'ordre en moto évidemment que ce serait
une faute la doctrine c'est de mettre
pied à terre et d'agir sauf évidemment
ça évidemment faut pas l'oublier le cas
d'extrême légitime défense sur la
dissolution de la braven non évidemment
je n'y suis pas favorable comme préfet
de police parce que cette unité dans les
dans le type de violence que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui avec des groupes
qui se dispersent qui sont très mobiles
pour pouvoir les rattraper les récupérer
les empêcher de nuire il faut se
déplacer très vite et la Bravet est
absolument indispensable et puis ensuite
vous avez parfois moi je n'ai pas à
commenter les propos de d'homme
politique j'ai évidemment beaucoup de
respect pour les fonctions politiques et
commencer par les parlementaires du
parti de Monsieur Mélenchon qui avec
lesquels je suis régulièrement en
contact pendant les manifestations qui
et qui m'appelle quand c'est compliqué
le discours d'aujourd'hui ce que je
n'accepte pas ce que je n'accepte pas
c'est évidemment quand je considère que
ces propos peuvent avoir un caractère
insultant et il m'arrive évidemment de
saisir la justice puisque je suis comme
autorité d'emploi responsable de la
protection de mes agents évidemment que
dire que des fonctionnaires mes
fonctionnaires de la brav il faut aller
les fesses il faut qu'ils aillent se
faire soigner parce qu'il y a des
problèmes psychologiques pour monter sur
une moto pour casser des gens évidemment
que de mon point de vue ça n'est pas
acceptable et je saisis la justice et
c'est la justice qui tranchera puisque
elle a été saisie sur une de sur une
saisine de ma part du procureur de la
République de Paris à partir de 500.000
sur l'Assemblée nationale peut décider
d'organiser un débat en séance publique
sur la pétition il y a 250 000
signatures ça vous inquiète pas non je
ne suis pas inquiet parce que la bravem
a montré à démontrer toute son
efficacité maintenant depuis qu'elle a
été créée depuis 2019 et il serait
totalement irresponsable de notre part
de renoncer à ces unités qui encore une
fois font un travail remarquable et
quand on a des cortèges chauffages comme
on a eu ces derniers soirs dans Paris
sans la bravem on aurait eu beaucoup de
difficultés à contenir certains
débordements il y a 72 heures ou quatre
jours un soir on avait quand même des
groupes qui se sont détachés d'une
manifestation déclarée je ne mélange pas
les deux les deux questions et qui
ciblaient sciemment l'hôtel de ville du
la mairie pardon du 11e arrondissement
et puis le commissariat du 11e et grâce
à la brave nous avons pu tout de suite
déployer devant ces deux sites publics
pour éviter des exactions les
manifestations en ce moment ce qui se
passe d'ailleurs partout en France et
notamment à Paris si vous êtes préfet de
police de Paris est-ce que ça vous
inquiète est-ce que vous dites qu'on n'a
jamais vu telle violence moi c'est ce
que disent les policiers qui sont sur le
terrain c'est ce qui me revient est-ce
que vous avez déjà vu une telle violence
est-ce que vous dites là c'est c'est
compliqué en plus c'est c'est très
récurrent parce que c'est vrai que les
gilets jaunes on se dit c'était une fois
par semaine là c'est encore plus
récurrent et c'est vrai qu'on dit que
sur le terrain la violence et nous il y
a une violence d'une minorité de
personnes qui sont essentiellement les
individus
ultra et donc encore une fois les
manifestations nous posent des problèmes
que lorsqu'il y a constitution du black
bloc dans les pré-cortèges les
manifestations syndicales se passent
bien et effectivement que le black bloc
prend à partie nos effectifs de manière
extrêmement violente il y a énormément
de jeux de projectiles de prise à partie
nous avons énormément de blessés donc
j'ai entre j'ai plus de 400 blessés
depuis le début du mouvement policier ou
gendarmes dont une quarantaine ont été
conduits ont été hospitalisées donc
évidemment qu'il y a un niveau de
violence qui est absolument intolérable
mais qui n'est que le fait d'une extrême
minorité et nous sommes là justement
pour maintenir cet ordre républicain et
empêcher ces individus de nuire et c'est
ce que nous faisons mais on ne fait pas
que les empêcher de nuire on ne fait pas
que éviter les exactions on protège
aussi souvent les cortèges syndicaux et
on permet à la liberté d'expression de
s'exprimer vous en tant que citoyen vous
êtes pour la retraite pour cette réforme
ou pas je n'ai pas à me prononcer sur
cette question voilà moi je suis pressé
je ne ferai aucun commentaire là-dessus
bien évidemment bien évidemment
vous savez quel âge vous monsieur j'ai
59 ans Monsieur 59
je voudrais qu'on revienne aussi sur sur
cet événement qui est passé vendredi
nous alors nous on voulait bien faire
puisqu'on a invité quatre policiers on a
dit qu'il y avait on a bien regardé ce
que dit le jeune homme dès le début il
dit il y a des moments à leur passer
tout à l'heure il y a des membres de la
bravème que je peux pas citer
apparemment il y en aurait un on est en
train d'enquêter et
c'est que des gens qui sont sur des
interventions à part lui qui étaient
débit de ses fonctions et qui fait
partie d'un syndicat de police nous on
voulait on voulait bien faire donc parce
qu'on avait donné la parole à la tente
d'un manifestant qui était dans un état
critique la veille donc l'avant veille
donc on voulait avoir aussi voilà la vie
de des personnes qui sont sur le terrain
de tout ce qui se passe et c'est vrai
que derrière voilà il y a eu la
préfecture de police de Paris donc ou
qui avait tweeté qui allait faire une
enquête sur sur ces personnes il faut
savoir que nous on n'était pas là pour
d'ailleurs on a vu le discours de ces de
ces jeunes hommes qui étaient tout à
fait construit et qui n'était pas contre
la police ou contre les autorités voilà
entre voilà
entre vous ou contre voilà c'était
vraiment ils avaient un discours assez
sensé et voilà vous avez dit vous allez
saisir le procureur de République pour
une enquête administrative nous on a
je vous dis l'identité de ces quatre
personnes on les a est-ce que vous
pouvez vous demander de vous les donner
ou pas parce qu'on les donnera pas pour
forcément non je peux pas vous demander
monsieur Aluna sais identités parce que
il y a une enquête administrative qui
est en cours l'IGPN est saisi et même
dans le cadre de l'enquête vous pouvez
pas nous il y aura probablement une
enquête judiciaire qui sera ouverte moi
j'ai saisi la procureur c'est elle qui
va moi je vais vous dire comment j'ai
vécu cette séquence me demandait ce sont
des effectifs qui viennent sur votre
plateau qui se revendiquent comme étant
membre d'une unité que je dirige alors
il y en a qu'un et c'était pas tout ça
moi je considère
quand je vois cette séquence que
j'apprends d'ailleurs que finalement
vous avez convoqué un fonctionnaire qui
a été révoqué et qui parle le nom de la
braven moi je considère
les brigades d'intervention tous les
gens qui ont vu cette séquence on
considéré que c'était des membres de la
bravème et je considère que ça jette le
discrédit cette séquence ils ont mal lu
alors il faut que moi je vous dis vous
me demandez mais vous me demandez
comment je j'ai vécu cette chose je vous
le dis très franchement pas voir ce qui
se passe sur les réseaux
discrédit sur l'ensemble des propos
qu'ils ont tenus et jetant aussi le
discrédit sur la Bravet elle-même que je
dirige que j'emploie dont je réponds
seul mais vous ferez bien pour ça que
c'est bien pour ça et c'est bien pour ça
parce que c'est bien pour ça que j'ai
accepté évidemment de venir sur votre
plateau le ministre de l'Intérieur me
l'a proposé pour que nous parlions comme
nous l'avait fait de maintien de l'ordre
mais c'est pour ça parce que c'est moi
qui porte la voie de la bravelle ou des
fonctionnaires qui me demandent
l'autorisation qui veulent s'exprimer en
plateau
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont venus aussi
masquer ce qui voulait pas qu'on les
reconnaisse le ministre a bien dit qu'on
était très transparent lui évidemment
mais moi aussi qui suis-je sous son
autorité moi quand j'ai des
fonctionnaires de police qui veulent
aller s'exprimer sur des plateaux mais
je les laisse faire surtout quand c'est
pour expliquer la difficulté du métier
et leur discours il était c'est le
discours que n'importe qui aurait eu
s'il avait été s'ils avaient été non
masqué je n'en sais rien en tout cas moi
ce qui me gêne c'est qu'il y a non
respect du devoir de réserve ça c'est un
problème en soi et comme autorité
d'emploi je suis obligé de vous le dire
y compris ce soir
c'est mon devoir de le dire le devoir de
réserve c'est important et quand vous
convoquez quand vous avez un
fonctionnaire non et vous avez un
fonctionnaire qui a été révoqué monsieur
Hanouna qui parle au nom de la braven
pour moi c'est un problème pour moi
c'est un nom il parlait au nom des
brigades d'intervention et en tant
qu'enseignant il a dit tout de suite
homme de terrain c'est normal j'ai envie
de tout le temps des gens qui ont déjà
été sur le terrain ou des gens qui ont
fait voilà même que ce soit dans
n'importe quel branche le métier corps
de métier donc voilà je vous le dis donc
ça ça n'a rien à voir il parlait pas au
nom de la braven et d'ailleurs il l'a
souligné tout de suite il a dit moi
attention je ne fais pas partie de la
moi-même je parle en tant comme de
terrain c'est le seul qui révoqué si
vous trouvez l'identité de ces trois des
trois autres vous allez les envier en
anglais administrativement
administrativement oui je ne peux pas
vous dire autre chose il y a un
manquement de voir de réserve pour celui
qui a évoqué je suis désolé mais il
porte un brassard polis il n'est plus
policier donc voilà il y a un certain
temps encore une fois encore une fois il
y a des investigations en cours moi il
m'appartient pas de me prononcer j'ai
fait mon devoir qui était de saisir
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale et de sais IR le parquet de
Paris voilà alors vous allez voir et
puis on verra puis vous verrez bien
qu'il n'a pas parlé au nom de la Brabant
après ce brassard police ou pas il
paraît qu'il fait partie d'un syndicat
de police encore donc vous vérifierez
mais il y a apparemment pratiquement sûr
qu'il fait encore partie d'un syndicat
de police
c'est lui qui sait identifié lui-même sa
réintégration exactement sur
l'intégration voilà exactement donc vous
verrez vous verrez vous mènerez
l'enquête et vous nous direz